all right what entertainment you have
for me today internet cat photo cat
photo range about people responding to a
tragedy incorrectly cat photo Jerry T
Lewin said
star battles is the worst franchise of
all time anyone who watches it is a
[ __ ]
no I will not engage no matter how wrong
he is he said Princess carrenza is a sad
excuse for a character and belongs in
the kitchen deep breath instead of
responding I can go get a cup of tea and
calm my nerves
Lukens is a worst director of all time
are you kidding me okay
calm down maybe it's time for a little
walk he said what you know what I'll
finally finish my novel
no I'll take up crocheting like I've
always wanted to Holland adopted baby
and raised her in a good household until
she's 18 and I send her off to a great
college
goddamnit
I'll train for the astronaut program at
NASA get accepted fly to Mars started
calling me up there wow this place is
beautiful
how much for not when I came up here to
begin with Wow I get service up here too
huh you mr. Jerry T luhan's are an
incredible idiot
not only did Star battles inspired
generation princess Carranza was the
first female character in history to
ever kill a man with her bare hands on
film sir she is more progressive and
creative than anything you could imagine
you chocolates swine I immediately
regret this